bertrand legrand médecin généraliste à
tourcoing dans le nord bonsoir monsieur
le grand merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors avant
d'évoquer un le bilan encore très lourd
ce soir je voulais vous faire réagir sur
ces différents traitements à l'écu dont
vient d'en voir l'un d'entre eux est ce
que vous en tant que médecin vous y
mettez beaucoup d'espoir pour un avenir
proche
alors oui on avait beaucoup d'espoirs
faut qu'ils aient un traitement qu'ils
finissent par sortir des études alors je
pense que pour le vernis colle c'est
clair un clairement quelque chose que
nous on ne verra pas en tant que médecin
généraliste c'est vraiment un produit
spécifique pour les réanimateurs pour
diminuer le temps de réanimation et
améliorer les les réponses à l'eau au
respirateur ce sens j'imagine que vous
avez forcément des liaisons avec
peut-être des confrères dans les
hôpitaux
aujourd'hui et qu'elle semble être le
traitement qui apporte le plus d'espoirs
dans cette crise alors j'ai sûrement
vous surprendre mais en fait on a très
peu de contacts avec les avec les le
monde hospitalier
le monde hospitalier c'est de faire et
c'est un monde le monde libéral c'est un
autre monde
on a souvent beaucoup de mal à faire que
faire cohabiter les deux et souvent
quand on voit un patient en libéral a
ensuite on l'envoie le en hôpital psy
c'est nécessaire et à partir de ce
moment là il ya une sorte de coupe ce
qui se fait entre les deux on reverra un
autre patient qu'elle a sortis de
l'hôpital
donc c'est pas tout à fait aussi fluide
que ce qu'on ne pourrait penser
effectivement c'est un point important
c'est quelque chose que vous déplorez ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas une piste justement
améliorer en ce sens peut-être moins
d'opacité entre les hôpitaux et la
médecine libérale on souvent de
quelqu'un qui marche avec deux jambes
l'hôpital marche avec une jambe
le libéral marche avec une autre jambe
si vous n'avez pas les deux jambes
vous ne marchez plat c'est exactement ça
le problème alors c'est pas forcément
illogique
c'était de cette communication c'est une
communication logique chacun est
concentré sur sa partie mais ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il faut pas qu'ils aient
une des deux parties qui flanche
aujourd'hui précisément la médecine
libérale
selon vous n'aurez peut-être pas un rôle
plus important à jouer on entendait
certains généralistes se plaint de
finale manquée cabinet aujourd'hui était
vide alors c'est un peu par sa
paradoxale moi je suis dans un secteur
où j'ai une forte densité de population
et donc on a un cluster sur tourcoing
qui est sain qui feinte qui est
manifeste sur le quartier où je suis et
donc mon activité personnelle n'a pas
vraiment diminué
on voit beaucoup moins des pathologies
habituelles mais on voit beaucoup plus
de personnes en que vides à l'intérieur
du cabinet sce qui n'est pas le cas
forcément partout dans tous les autres
quartiers
cc c'est un peu complexe mais je pense
que les médecins libéraux se doivent
aussi de contacter leurs patients
chroniques de ne pas les laisser dans la
dans la nature et de prendre tous les
outils qui sont nécessaires pour pour
eux pour permettre cela et je salue la
décision de nos autorités de tutelle qui
ont permis en fait de prendre le tout
simplement le téléphone comme
téléconsultation parce que en définitive
c'est toujours le téléphone qui reste là
le moyen de publication de plus simple
pour nouveaux médecins justement sa
lettre ma prochaine question comment
vous travaillez puisque vous vous dites
vous faites partie de ces médecins qui
n'ont pas baissé leur activité ce n'est
pas le cas de tous effectivement puisque
la plupart du temps n'ont pu venir en
cabinet vous travaillez
quasiment la majorité du temps par télé
travail par écran interposé comment ça
se passe
alors on a changé complètement notre
manière de travailler
on a adapté le cabinet pour pouvoir voir
des patients que vide et donc du coup
très clairement j'ai une zone de
déshabillage où j'ai sacrifié un bureau
pour le faire ou moi et ma femme on est
deux médecins dans le cabinet on se
change systématiquement de la tête aux
pieds
avant de commencer à travailler on a mis
en place des protections de plexiglas
pour la secrétaire pour nous mêmes on a
réorganisé en supprimant la totalité de
notre matériel de manière à pouvoir
examiner les patients deux bouts et dans
un temps le plus court possible génie
dans mon jardin des abris au cas où il
pleuvrait alors journal de la chance y'a
pas encore plus mais vraiment on a
refondé complètement notre manière
d'examiner les gens de manière à
diminuer le risque lié en fait si vous
voulez à la charge virale
ils pourraient nous transmettre ou que
nous-mêmes pourrions leur transmettre
j'ai qu'on sait pas exactement dans
quelle situation chacun se trouve en
termes de stocks de masques notamment
c'est évidemment c'est le grand sujet
non non non on n'a pas de on n'a pas de
masque pour être très clair on a eu une
dotation de 50 masques pour trois
soignants la femme plus à une assistante
qui est il était donné en tout début de
l'épidémie et là je pourrais aller
rechercher 18 masques et c'est tout ce
que j'ai eu je n'ai pas eu d'autres
masques ce n'est même pas les bons
masquer ce qu'on nous donne c'est des
masques chirurgicaux donc des masques
pour éviter que nous conte un mignon par
nos postillons les patients et non pas
des masques pour nous protéger nous on
est totalement démunie de toute
protection
aujourd'hui on parlait évidemment
beaucoup d effet
lui confinement est ce que vous vous les
avez observé sachant vous l'avez dit
vous-même que vous exercez à tourcoing
c'est un quartier dit sensible
est ce que les français de votre côté
dans mon quartier respecte ce
confinement
je pense que quand les quand mes
patients ont vu comment je travaille et
comment on avait changé qu'on
fondamentalement le cabinet en passant
un examen le plus rapide possible le
plus minimaliste sans toucher personne
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
n'était pas du tout courant chez moi ils
ont compris qu'on était passé dans un
autre stade de la médecine qui ont été
passées en médecine de guerre au sens
propre du terme
et je pense que ça les a fait changer
énormément après certains ne comprennent
pas certains n'ont pas envie de
comprendre d'autres sont limités dans
leur capacité de compréhension des
consignes fait pas toujours évident de
comprendre ce qu'il faut faire il faut
pas faire d'ailleurs le gouvernement et
lui-même pas très clair dans les
conseils qu'il donne et nous même
parfois nous pouvons péché par excès ce
qui rend incompréhensible notre
communication mais c'est important que
chacun comprenne que le virus se propage
assez facilement et assez rapidement et
donc du coup forcément les zones les
plus denses sont les zones les plus
touchées alors un nouveau bilan ce soir
comme chaque soir les 1911 en france me
133 décès de plus est-ce que clairement
on est dans le pic
vous avez dit 1 prédit un tout pour le 6
avril est ce qu on y est selon vous
aujourd'hui je ne sais je n'ai aucune
idée de ce qui nous attend à l'avenir
puisque je vous rappelle que nous
n'avons aucune idée non plus du nombre
de personnes qui sont atteintes
aujourd'hui puisqu'on ne regarde pas et
qu'on ne teste pas assez mais
aujourd'hui les morts qui arrive en
surnombre par rapport à la courbe
italiennes sont des morts liés aux
élections municipales il ya ça fait
aucun doute sur la question 44 % de
votants c'est le frelon l'événement
majeur et on est pile poil dans le
timing des élections en termes de décès
donc voilà que chacun regarde avec
certaines est ainsi une certaine
rétrospective sur les actions qu'ils ont
menées soit par défaut
de puissance à dire qu'il fallait les
arrêter soit parce que tout simplement
ils ont été totalement irresponsable et
on fait un petit jeu politique de
vouloir s'opposer à l'arrêt des
municipales questions que vous vous le
constatez clairement vous voyez des
patients aujourd'hui dans votre cabinet
atteint de corona virus qui est
clairement sont allés voter aurait
contracté la maladie selon vous à ce
moment là c'était je n'ai pas besoin
d'être grand clerc pour se rendre compte
qu'il ya une corrélation qui est forte
aujourd'hui
si on reprend les courbes de mortalité
on se rend parfaitement compte que nous
étions en dessous de la courbe italienne
et que nous l'avons croisée à la hausse
très rapidement pile poil 14 jours dans
la f1 à partir de quatorze jours après
l'élection ce qui correspond
parfaitement à léa d'histoire naturelle
de la maladie et donc il ya qu un seul
événement majeur qui a eu durant france
à ce moment là on peut dire que ce sont
les promeneurs et ses médias pas 44% de
promeneurs sur inquiet c'est pas vrai
donc le seul événement qui puisse
expliquer une chose pareille c'est des
élections peut-être le rat les
rapatriements de stations de ski sont
faits à l'arête etc
mais on peut mettre la corrélation de
manière totalement scientifique sans
aucune difficulté
merci beaucoup bertrand legrand médecin
généraliste à tourcoing dans le nord
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france